Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
On passe un peu plus de 99 000 heures
à travailler au cours de notre vie,
c’est-à-dire onze ans et demi d’affilée.
Dit comme ça, ça fait un peu peur.
Alors autant bien choisir son métier.
Je pense que jusque-là,
on est tous d’accord.
Sans vouloir généraliser,
jusqu’à il y a quelques années encore,
lorsqu’on se renseignait sur un métier,
le salaire était majoritairement
le 1er critère que l’on regardait.
Aujourd’hui, un métier n’est plus vu
comme un simple moyen
de gagner de l’argent.
Il est plutôt vu
comme un moyen de s’épanouir
en faisant quelque chose qui a du sens,
en faisant quelque chose
que l’on aime au quotidien.
Cette notion de quotidien est propre
à chaque métier,
que ce soit par ses missions, ses outils,
son environnement, son rythme de travail,
ses collaborateurs.
Chacun de ces paramètres fait que chaque
métier est unique et se vit différemment,
mais la manière dont il se vit est
trop difficilement transmissible
par une simple fiche métier.
Donc, les moyens qui semblaient
suffisants encore hier
en termes d’information sur les métiers,
ne sont peut-être
plus suffisants aujourd’hui.
Pourquoi ? Car les attentes
ne sont plus les mêmes :
on est de plus en plus en quête
de sens pour tout ce que l’on fait.
Finalement, peut-être que le meilleur
moyen de découvrir un métier,
c’est de le vivre.
Pour ça, jusqu’à aujourd’hui, on a
le stage de découverte de troisième.
Mais on ne va pas se mentir,
la plupart des collégiens ne le font pas
selon le métier qu’ils veulent découvrir,
mais selon le réseau de connaissances
des parents car c’est compliqué à trouver.
Ensuite, sur Internet, on trouve beaucoup
de vidéos, des interviews, des reportages.
On a aussi des salons, des forums métiers
organisés par les lycées.
Tous ces moyens sont louables ;
loin de moi l’idée de les dévaloriser.
Mais je trouve qu’ils manquent
encore crucialement de lien
avec les attentes qu’ont les jeunes -
et je dirais même avec les modes de
consommation de l’information des jeunes.
Si je vous parle de ça aujourd’hui,
ça peut sembler être un raisonnement
très simple - il l’est à mes yeux -
mais je pense sincèrement qu’on n’a pas
besoin d’aller chercher très loin
pour avoir des idées qui peuvent
changer les façons de penser ou de faire.
Je vais vous expliquer ce qui m’amène
aujourd’hui à vous parler de tout ça.
Ma maman est assistante maternelle
et j’ai donc grandi avec plein d’enfants
qui ont grandi en même temps que moi.
Au moment du collège-lycée,
à la période cruciale de l’orientation,
on leur pose souvent la question :
« Tu veux faire quoi plus tard ? »
Et là en général - on a tous été
dans cette situation -
si on n’est pas sûr
de ce qu’on veut faire,
on a des petits moments de doute, de peur,
on est plutôt anxieux face
à cette question.
Et s’il y a des parents à côté,
on voit que le sentiment
est plutôt partagé
et qu’ils se sentent même démunis
pour aider leurs enfants.
Ensuite, j’ai beaucoup grandi
avec des enfants et je les suis -
je les suis très souvent pour la plupart.
Ensuite, j’ai un filleul, Marius,
qui est en plein dans cette phase.
Il a toujours été attiré par l’art,
il a une façon de dessiner
qui m’a toujours fascinée.
Il est vraiment très, très doué pour ça.
J’ai un ami qui est dans ce domaine,
dans l’animation 3D,
ceux qui font les beaux films d’animation.
Un jour, il me montrait quels sont ses
différents outils, ses logiciels,
les différentes étapes de création
d’un film d’animation.
Il est si passionné par ce qu’il fait
qu’il en était véritablement passionnant.
En rentrant chez moi,
je me suis dit que ce serait génial que
je fasse se rencontrer mon filleul et Théo
pour qu’il puisse lui parler de son métier
comme il venait de le faire.
Peut être ferait-il naître
en mon filleul une vocation
et à partir de là, son orientation
se verrait complètement simplifiée.
Ça m’a hantée.
Je continue d’y penser et je me dis que
cette façon de découvrir les métiers
au travers de personnes passionnées,
il fallait absolument [l’étendre]
à tous les jeunes.
Ça paraît très simple, dit comme ça,
mais dans les moyens existants
que j’ai énumérés tout à l’heure,
combien permettent vraiment
de découvrir un métier
au travers d’un professionnel passionné ?
Très peu.
Donc j’ai continué cette réflexion,
notamment dans le cadre
de mon projet de fin d’études
lorsque j’étais en master.
J’ai rapidement observé
que tout ce qui est digital offre
beaucoup de possibilités aujourd’hui,
surtout que les jeunes ont de plus
en plus leur téléphone greffé à la main.
Et surtout, j'ai observé tout ce qui est
usage des réseaux sociaux qu'ils ont tous.
Et même si certains de mes professeurs
n’étaient pas très fans du concept,
j’ai persévéré car j’y croyais.
Au culot, j’ai candidaté
à des concours d’entrepreneuriat.
J’en ai fait un 1er, j’ai gagné un prix,
j’en ai fait un 2e, j’ai encore gagné.
C’était assez fou ; moi-même, j’étais
surprise de l’ampleur que ça prenait.
Donc, je me suis dit :
« Feu, je fonce.
Je ne peux pas m’arrêter à un simple
projet d’étude ou de concours,
il faut que je le concrétise. »
Rapidement, comme je voulais donner
de l’ampleur à ce projet.
j’ai cherché un associé qui ait des
compétences complémentaires aux miennes -
ce fut Corentin Bouffard,
qui est aujourd’hui mon binôme.
Ensemble, on a commencé
à travailler dessus
en faisant des études de marché,
en rôdant notre modèle économique,
en développant l’application
et en développant la partie partenariat.
Encore une fois, comme les concours, au
culot, on a répondu à un appel à projets
du Ministère de l’Éducation
et de celui de l’Enseignement supérieur.
A nouveau, on s’est dit :
« Qui ne tente rien n’a rien »
et on a bien fait de le tenter
puisqu’on en est lauréat.
On a un accompagnement
de leur part sur deux ans,
alors même que l’application
n’était pas sortie.
Ça nous a permis d’agrandir l’équipe.
Ça nous a permis de sortir l'application
dans de bonnes conditions.
Elle est donc sortie en ce début d'année,
en janvier 2021.
Je ne suis pas là
pour vous en faire la promotion,
mais vu le sujet que j’aborde,
je pense que c’est utile
que je vous montre
où nous a menés toute cette réflexion.
Je vais montrer comment elle fonctionne.
Vous allez voir que dans mes mots,
il y en a beaucoup qu’utilisent les jeunes
quand ils parlent des réseaux sociaux.
Là notamment, on a ce que
l’on appelle un swipe des métiers.
Quand l’utilisateur arrive dessus,
il va simplement glisser
à gauche ou à droite
pour indiquer s’il like ou pas le métier.
Il le retrouvera ailleurs
dans l'application.
On reprend vraiment -
vous le verrez plusieurs fois -
les codes des applications
de réseaux sociaux
que tout le monde utilise aujourd’hui.
Première façon
de découvrir des métiers.
Puis il y a notre page d’accueil
avec un métier à la une, des suggestions,
de nombreuses collections par
secteurs d’activité, centres d’intérêt,
des teasers métiers
qui se lancent automatiquement.
C’est un modèle d’application
qui est utilisé très régulièrement
pour d’autres domaines.
Lorsqu’on clique sur un métier,
on arrive sur le profil.
Le métier est d’abord présenté
sous forme de teaser -
exactement comme un film - pour rendre le
métier un peu plus sexy, si je puis dire,
et donner envie de découvrir
un peu plus le métier.
Le concept phare de notre
application, j’y arrive,
c’est lorsqu’on s’abonne à un métier -
Tout est gratuit,
mais lorsqu’on s’abonne à un métier,
pendant une semaine, on reçoit
des vidéos d’un vrai professionnel,
qui se sera filmé lui-même
dans son quotidien avec son téléphone.
Au fil de la journée, on reçoit
des vidéos de sa part
où il explique les différentes étapes
de ses missions, ses outils,
les personnes avec qui il travaille,
l’environnement de travail, son rythme,
tout pour donner une vision
exhaustive de son métier,
pour nous montrer toutes les facettes.
In fine, ce qu’on a créé,
c’est un peu un stage de découverte de 3e,
mais digitalisé,
sans contraintes de temps, de déplacement
ou de réseau de connaissances.
Si papa et maman ne connaissent pas
de plombier ou d’architecte,
je peux quand même découvrir le métier
au travers de l’application
n’importe où, n’importe quand.
Cette application a été un moyen pour nous
de créer une nouvelle façon
de découvrir les métiers,
une nouvelle façon de s’orienter,
mais pas que.
On a aussi eu cette envie de démontrer que
la réflexion autour de l’orientation
peut se faire autrement.
Les moments clés
où on réfléchit à notre orientation,
c’est souvent quand on doit faire
des choix de formation en 3e,
quand on doit choisir
entre un bac général ou un bac pro ;
et au lycée, quand on doit réfléchir
aux études supérieures.
Mais in fine, quand on est
dans cette réflexion,
on a des objectifs très court-termistes.
C’est : « L’année prochaine,
qu’est-ce que je fais comme études ? »
Rapidement, on s’est dit
qu’il fallait peut-être inverser ça,
qu’il fallait peut-être commencer
par la finalité, c’est-à-dire le métier.
Si on découvre plein de métiers et
qu’on trouve celui qui nous fait vibrer,
qui nous fait vraiment envie.
les études à suivre pour y arriver
vont en découler très naturellement.
De plus, la formation va être
beaucoup plus plaisante à suivre
car on sait qu’on a un vrai but derrière.
On ne va pas attendre de voir
quels seront les débouchés plus tard
sans trop savoir au final où on va.
Voilà notre réflexion
autour de l’orientation.
Mais il ne faut pas penser
qu’une fois qu’on a eu cette réflexion,
on n’y pense plus.
Au contraire.
Que l’on ait 18, 22, 38 ou 55 ans,
il y a des phases dans notre vie où on
réfléchit de nouveau à notre orientation
puisque, toujours
dans cette quête de sens,
on va réfléchir à ce qui nous fait vibrer,
nos envies vont évoluer.
C’est tout à fait normal de vouloir
changer de voie en cours de route.
Il ne faut pas avoir peur de le faire,
puisqu’au final,
ce dont on s’est rendu compte aussi,
c’est que l’orientation se construit
tout au long d’une vie,
et d'autant plus aujourd'hui.
C'est bien vrai puisqu'il y a beaucoup
de passerelles qui sont possibles.
Tout ça pour vous dire que,
comme pour beaucoup de choses,
l’orientation et les approches
que l’on en a
doivent continuellement évoluer,
comme les nouvelles générations
et les nouveaux usages qu’ils font des
réseaux sociaux et de la partie digitale.
À notre échelle, on essaie,
tant bien que mal,
de changer l’approche de l’orientation,
les moyens de découvrir les métiers.
On a créé cet outil avec pour but
de moderniser l’orientation,
de lui donner un nouveau souffle,
pour aider des milliers de personnes -
peut-être, on l’espère -
à trouver leur voie.
J’espère que ça vous aura intéressé,
que ça vous aura plu,
donné envie de réfléchir
à votre orientation
ou de lancer des projets.
Je vous souhaite de trouver
un métier qui vous fasse vibrer
et de vous donner les moyens
pour en faire votre quotidien.
(Applaudissements)